you founded this company twelve years
ago right tell him how old you were I
was 19
don't worry about the future we're in
good news Elizabeth Holmes was
everything Silicon Valley and the media
could hope for a brilliant young female
entrepreneur who dropped out of Stanford
at the age of 19 to start a company
called Theron owes Theron has promised
to save people from pain and disease
through early detection and lead the way
into an era of cheaper more consumer
driven health care Theron s's big idea
was to replace traditional venous blood
draws in a doctor's office hospital or
lab with simple finger prints one day
the company promised patients would do
the tests at home and then upload the
results for their doctor's homes stacked
her board of directors with
establishment heavyweights such as
George Shultz Henry Kissinger and
General James Madison she cozied up to
Bill and Hillary Clinton she also
catched hundreds of millions of dollars
from investors that included the
wal-mart heirs Rupert Murdoch and Betsy
DeVos for a time her company was worth
more than Spotify or uber but today
theranos is on the verge of liquidation
and its backers have seen their
investments completely wiped out Homes
has been unmasked as a fraud and it's
now facing possible criminal charges
the man responsible for uncovering the
truth about their nose is John Kerry rue
a veteran investigative journalist at
The Wall Street Journal his dogged
reporting revealed Holmes's tactics of
flattery and intimidation that fooled
investors and the press allowing its
founder to keep up the deception for as
long as she did when Kerry ruse stories
on thoroughness started appearing in
October 2015
Holmes went on the offensive depicting
herself as a Silicon Valley disrupter
who had become the target of a smear
campaign orchestrated by established
interests what do you think's going on
here this is what happens when you work
to change things and first they think
you're crazy then they fight you and
then all of a sudden you change the
world with Cary Roos reporting turning
up one revelation after another and
regulators finally cracking down
Holmes's public demeanor shifted I feel
devastated that we did not catch and fix
these issues faster though she never
went so far as to apologize to the
thousands of patients whose health
Theron OSes product had put at risk i
sat down with John Kerry rude to talk
about his new book on thier nose bad
blood secrecy and lies in a Silicon
Valley startup which has made the New
York Times bestseller list and will soon
be made into a movie starring Jennifer
Lawrence as Elizabeth Holmes bad blood
raises tough questions about the failure
of regulators to stop their enough the
infatuation of the public and the press
with the mystique of Silicon Valley and
the Shadowlands where innovation
capitalism and fraud sometimes get lost
so what was thoroughness and who is
Elizabeth Holmes fairness is a
Diagnostics startup that was founded in
2003 in Silicon Valley by a young
Stanford dropout named Elizabeth Holmes
she was midway through her sophomore
year she had this vision of a medical
device that that would test your blood
at first it was a an armband they would
have these little micro needles that
would prick your blood and diagnose what
ailed you and then simultaneously inject
the appropriate drug and so in fact the
the word Thera nose was a combination of
the words therapy and diagnosis that
original idea proved to be you know more
science fiction than than anything that
was really feasible and she and her
co-founder realized that pretty quickly
and so after a couple months they
pivoted to what they wanted to they
wanted to build a device that was
inspired from the portable glucose
monitors that diabetes patients used to
monitor their blood sugar but Elizabeth
wanted it to test all you know to do all
the love lab tests known to man which
you know was gonna make it a lot more
complicated and and but a lot more
exciting a lot more exciting too because
the proposition was going to be that
from a prick just a prick of blood from
your finger you'd be able to run all lab
tests and
be able to do it quickly the results and
do Diagnostics on you know various types
of prescriptions and all of that yeah I
mean it would be anywhere from several
hundred to several thousand blood tests
you know ranging from the common blood
test that your doctor will prescribe
just you know to check up on how you're
doing to test to detect you know certain
types of cancers she was what 19 or 20
to 19 or they dropped out late 1300s
like Steve Jobs Steve Jobs was famous
for you know what became known as the
reality distortion field right but
people in the room with him you know had
to bow down to his magnetism and his
charisma a lot of people talked about
Elizabeth Holmes in a similar way what
is the essential difference between
Steve Jobs ability to distort reality
and Elizabeth Holmes right so Elizabeth
did idolized jobs it was to the point
that she started as you mentioned
wearing black turtlenecks and she wanted
their nose to fly an apple flag you know
at half-mast the day that Steve Jobs
died she referred to him as Steve as if
she had been best friends with him she
hired the same ad agency that Apple had
used for some of its legendary ad
campaigns when she found out that that
added agency had met with Steve Jobs on
Wednesdays she decreed that she would
have her meetings with the agency shiet
Day on Wednesdays and as you say she did
share this trait which is like jobs she
had this ability to sort of put a spell
on people with her big blue eyes that
blinked rarely and this deep voice of
hers whenever there is a quote-unquote
glass ceiling there's an iron woman
right behind it
and also her intelligence she's a very
intelligent woman I would say that the
big difference and the reason why was a
fatal mistake for her to model herself
after Jobs and Apple is that Apple was a
computer company Thera nose was not a
traditional tech company it was actually
a medical company a health care company
because it's device was a blood testing
machine that patients and doctors were
going to rely on and did rely on for a
while for blood tests and as Elizabeth
said at the height of her fame 70% of
medical decisions that doctors make are
based on blood tests when you're in
medical space in the medical realm if
you deliver a product that doesn't work
then lives are at stake is there
anything at all to her vision because I
mean the way that it's played out you
know there isn't there are notices near
liquidation at this point and we'll get
to that
is there anything to her vision of a
cheap you know kind of portable
incredibly comprehensive non-invasive
blood testing a technology if she had
been able to pull off and if the company
had been able to pull off what she
claimed to have pulled off I think it
would have been in advance for medicine
it would have been a game-changer to be
able to draw to test so many analytes
off just a small sample of blood do it
quickly do it at a you know a fraction
of the price of competitors she liked to
say that because the test would be so
user-friendly and painless and cheap
that people would get their blood tested
more often and as a result diseases
would get diagnosed at an earlier stage
so it's a very appealing vision right
and it's a logical one if the underlying
technology exists and works and the
problem is that it never did at their
nose and to this day you know when my
first investigation came out in late
2015 a week or two later she was at a
conference and she said we're gonna put
out data soon you know disproving this
this reporters reporting and data you
never lies and it was only in January of
this
year January 2018 that Theron has
finally published its first
peer-reviewed paper and a scientific
journal about it's the last iteration of
its technology the mini lab and what was
amazing about it is the study had been
conducted with regular blood draws with
the you know the old-fashioned way with
the big syringe moreover it only covered
a couple of blood tests and some of the
tests didn't agree with the results of
conventional machines which fairness had
to concede in the paper and then last
but not least to run these these various
tests fairness had had to configure the
Machine differently each time because it
still hadn't figured out how to fit all
the instruments into one box so this was
a far cry from what she had promised as
far back as September of 2013 when she
went live with her finger stick tests in
Walgreens stores first in Palo Alto and
then in Arizona heathered Holmes and her
partners the top level people keep this
story alive I mean that this this
beautiful dream of a kind of home lab
where you would be able to you know be
checking your blood you know almost like
you're you know checking you know peeing
on a strip or something like that right
how did they keep that hidden for so
long well there's a culture of fear and
intimidation at their nose going back to
its earliest days Holmes actually sued
some ex employees and in 2007 and this
culture got worse and and was really
enforced by her boyfriend a man named
Sonny ball Hwanhee who was 19 years her
senior and who's a guy who had made a
lot of money during the Internet boom
and he joined fairness and late 2009 and
and really became the enforcer of this
culture you know a quasi tyrant who
silenced everyone and treated people
badly fired people all the time
in addition to Sonny what you had also
was you had David Boies as the company's
outside counsel starting in 2011 so
legendary litigator who did Bush v Gore
who became a champion
for gay marriage right and you know
arguably the the most famous and most
feared lawyer in America and he started
working as outside counsel for
thoroughness in 2011 and he acted as a
scarecrow for employees they were afraid
of him
they were afraid that if they spoke up
either internally or after they left
went to the media or to regulators that
their nose would come after them and sue
them and that David Boies this you know
great lawyer with a great track record
who's also ruthless and feared would be
the one coming after them
you mentioned Walgreens why did
Walgreens and and there were other
companies that bought into the vision or
started using the services or trying
them out why did they buy in if this
wasn't really working this is actually
one of the craziest parts of the story
is Walgreens did not do really any due
diligence it hired as I explained in in
one chapter of the book it hired a lab
consultant named Kevin hunter in 2010
when it began talking to thier no sand
and hunters job was to vet the Thera
knows technology and help Walgreens
decide whether to actually forge on with
this partnership and Hunter traveled
several times to Palo Alto to meet with
Elizabeth and Sonny and he started
smelling a rat early on and he tried to
alert the people who had hired him at
Walgreens and he just could not get
through to them they they had this fear
of missing out on the Thera knows
technology they were obsessed with this
notion that if they didn't pursue it
then their nose would turn around and
forge a deal with CVS their arch rival
based in Rhode Island and so this this
fear of missing out drove Walgreens
amazingly to ignore its own consultants
how much of that is I mean its fear of
missing out but then it's also the the
kind of lure and mystique of Silicon
Valley which is the shiny coastal bauble
versus being in a you know a kind of
19th century business of retail right of
drugstores where you know you're selling
more and more as-seen-on-tv stuff I mean
is did that I had played a role for sure
I mean Walgreens is this stodgy you know
year-old business based in Chicago far
from the razzle-dazzle of Silicon Valley
the thing that that was a factor here
also is Thera nose had a major champion
within the ranks of Walgreens executives
in the person of jay rosen who was a
trained doctor and who was absolutely
head over heels for Elizabeth he went by
the nickname dr. J he liked to high-five
people instead of shaking their hands
and he always introduced himself as hi
I'm dr. J and I used to play basketball
which he thought was a hilarious joke
this guy was like a Silicon Valley
groupie and he managed to convince the
CFO the chief financial officer of
Walgreens to also get onboard with the
pilot and the two of them really were
big champions for this partnership the
board of directors and kind of
high-profile investors and thoroughness
also kind of you know in all-star cast
including people like George Shultz
Henry Kissinger general mattis would
what role did that play I mean that the
cultivation of these kind of superstar
you know hangers on this is something
that Elizabeth did from the very
beginning she cultivated the backing of
someone who was older more experienced
and had a good reputation the first
person she did that with was Channing
Robertson her engineering professor at
Stanford he was a star of the Stanford
School of Engineering and he joined her
board when she founded their nose and
accompanied her to pitch meetings with
VCS then a year or two later she met
Donald el Lucas a well-known venture
capitalists in Silicon Valley who grooms
area Larry Ellison the Oracle founder
and helped him take Oracle public in the
mid-80s
and then unfortunately Don Lucas started
developing Alzheimer's disease in the
2010/2011 period so she pivoted to
George Schultz the famous former
Secretary of State and crafted the
Reagan administration's foreign policy
is credited by many as having won the
Cold War and long-standing interest in
the kind of the pharma industry drug
legalization
I mean he's an interesting he's a great
older statesman who's widely respected
yes and he lives his house is right off
the Stanford campus on Stanford land and
he's also passionate about science and
so when he met Elizabeth in 2011 he was
immediately taken in by her wowed by
what she claimed her technology could do
join her board and then proceeded to
introduce her to all his buddies at the
Hoover Institution the conservative
think-tank on the Stanford campus and
that's how she came to meet Henry
Kissinger bill Perry who had been
Secretary of Defense under Clinton Bill
Frist Sam Nunn Admiral rough head and
pretty soon all these guys were on the
board - Elizabeth lured them with grants
of stock and and you know before you
knew it she had this this board
chock-full of these amazing you know
people with amazing resumes as I was
reading the book and and following the
account I mean you know they kind of
feminist in me cropped up I mean like
part of this it just sounds like she is
you know really working like I mean in a
kind of old screwball comedy or
something she's a femme fatale who is
like wrapping her you know these guys
around her finger I mean is that I don't
work here that was definitely at work
and I know you know it's pretty
controversial to say this mid the me2
movement but you know the 15 year
history of the company shows that that
is what she did over and over again
these older men
you know she wrapped them around her
finger she made them support her and
believed in her and I think she did it
in part with her intelligence she's very
smart woman and she did it with her
charm you know she has these big blue
eyes and she has this charisma and they
were kind of taken in and and you know
it ranges from Channing Robertson and
Don Lucas at the beginning to Kissinger
and then David Boies and Rupert Murdoch
at the end of the story we're gonna talk
about Murdoch in a second and this is a
good time to bring up the press because
so you know you have companies like
Walgreens buying in without doing due
diligence you have investors buying in
without really understanding what's
going on you talk about how the
chief financial officer was like you
know I don't really understand this and
it doesn't seem to be working but I
guess it does I mean like there's that
the press was generally uncritical of
her and in many cases they're the ones
who kind of made her into an investment
or a you know a Silicon Valley superstar
why did the press buy in isn't the
presses supposed to be the the Bulldog
and the watchdog of democracy and of the
market well she worked the press
expertly I mean one thing that should be
noted is the first mainstream
publication that put her on the map was
my newspaper The Wall Street Journal the
editorial page of the journal did a
friendly interview with her in its
Saturday edition and a column called the
weekend interview and this was back in
September of 2013 and it coincided with
the launch of fairness fingerstick tests
in Walgreens stores and then story I
would say that really rocketed her to
fame about six or eight months later was
the cover story in Fortune magazine that
was published in June 2014 and she's
shown you know with a black turtleneck
and and bright red lipstick the headline
I think is the CEO is out for blood and
that was a really arresting photo and it
really made her celebrity in Silicon
Valley and beyond that said I don't
blame the press too much because people
like Roger parla who wrote that cover
story and then Ken Auletta who wrote a
long profile of Elizabeth Holmes six
months later in The New Yorker were
outright lied to by her I mean you know
they they were disabled over you're a
reporter you know when your mother tells
you she loves you you check it out I
mean kind of let it fits into this right
old man kind of right
no and and Roger pearl Karloff was a
legal correspondent for fortune and and
Ken Auletta writes mostly about media
and Technology not health care neither
of them had any expertise in medicine
and certainly not laboratory science
Roger went and talked to all these
larger-than-life board members and and
kind of used them to get corroboration
that from them that she was the real
thing and and all he heard from them was
you know gushing words of praise yeah I
mean I guess that they were really
deceived and they didn't necessarily go
into those
interviews and into those stories
thinking that they should be on their
guards about you know someone who was
who was a pathological liar which she
was is there any reason to believe that
actual individuals died or were harmed
by the rollout of fairness it's very
hard to to get an answer to that
question because the the correlation
between you know someone having a bad
health outcome and a blood test is it's
very hard to scientifically prove it
that said I came across more than a
dozen examples of patients who'd gotten
unreliable test results from thier nose
in most cases luckily their doctors were
suspicious about these results and sent
them you know to have their blood to be
drawn and retested elsewhere one of the
stories that I talk about in the book is
that of a real estate agent in Phoenix
who had ringing in her ear and so her
doctor had sent her to thier nose to get
her blood tested be a finger stick and
her results came back and I think six
values came back abnormal and the doctor
given the symptom which was ringing in
the ear became very concerned that she
was on the cusp of a stroke and
immediately sent her to the emergency
room the patients spent four hours in
the hospital and you know underwent a
battery of tests finally the hospital
ran her labs again and they were normal
she then had more tests MRIs over the
ensuing week until she she and her
doctor finally came to the conclusion
that the Thera nurse tests had been
inaccurate so that gives you an idea of
the the health scare that this company
put some people through you had
mentioned Rupert Murdoch in passing you
work for The Wall Street Journal which
is owned by Rupert Murdoch ur by his
corporation there's a story in there
when you I mean you started writing
about darkness and you started
uncovering a lot of weirdness going on
and a lot of you know dicey things talk
a little bit about what happened Murdoch
was an investor in thyrion-- house right
simultaneously you know owned the
newspaper there controlled the newspaper
you were writing for and there comes a
moment where thorough notes ghost
and put the screws to him does your does
Rupert Murdock does sir Murdock or what
Lord Murdock acquit himself well I mean
I would say that in the end he does when
I started digging into their notes in
early February 2015 he was a month away
or three weeks away from investing on 25
million dollars at which he proceeded to
do I had no idea that he was an investor
he had no idea that I was working on an
investigation of the company and the
first I heard of I heard a vague rumor
that he might be an investor a couple
days before we went to print with my
first story wasn't able to confirm that
and then heard rumors sporadically in
the in the following months and year was
never able to confirm those rumors
finally a year after my first story was
published as I went on book leave to
write this book I was able to confirm
with this source that not only was he an
investor but he was the single largest
investor he had put in 125 million
dollars into the company which stunned
me and I also learned shortly thereafter
that she had had several meetings with
him one at their nose headquarters in
Palo Alto a couple months before my
story was published in which she brought
up my story and said that I had gathered
a lot of damaging and false information
and that it shouldn't be published she
hoped he would kill it and then again
just two weeks in late September just
two weeks before my we went to press
with my story and that time it was in
the news court building on the eighth
floor where Murdock had his office and I
was on the fifth floor working on the
story and I had no idea she was in the
building
hmm where were the regulators in all of
this because it is a health care company
because it's it's drawing blood etc
there's a vast array of you know this
this isn't the Wild West or anything who
were the regulators and where were they
in in all of this well just like she
played the press she really played
regulators so you have two Health
regulators that are involved in
regulating the lab industry you have the
FDA which reviews and approves the
Vittoria equipment that laboratories buy
and use in their labs and then you have
the Centers for Medicare and Medicaid
Services which not many people know
aside from running the Medicare program
has a second job which is to be the
overseer of clinical laboratories in
this country and it does that by doing
inspections every two years and by
having labs do this thing called
proficiency testing basically what she
did was she navigated a gray area
between these these two regulators and
she maintained that her tests the the
thoroughness
tests were what are called laboratory to
develop tests which are not test run on
commercial machines that have been
approved by the FDA they're let their
tests that are fashioned by labs with
their own methods and that's a part of
the lab business that isn't hasn't been
closely regulated or policed and the FDA
for a while was beginning to make noise
about wanting to police police it more
aggressively that's now changed under
the the Trump administration but so she
really drove a truck through this this
loophole at the same time she paid lip
service to the fact that she was
voluntarily submitting each of her
proprietary tests to the FDA that turned
out to be in part her undoing because
after she submitted data for a few of
these fingerstick tests my source is
that the FDA told me that that the data
actually didn't look good
and aside from hearing from me because I
was running by an FDA source of mine
what I was learning in my reporting
trying to figure out if it was allowed
and so the FDA was concerned by what it
was hearing from me but it was also
concerned by the clinical data it had
ever received from fairness and decided
it should inspect the company and see if
it could find any better data on site
and it turned out that they did inspect
they couldn't find any better data and
they they said you know we better shut
this down because these these tests are
gonna be inaccurate and and unreliable
in the large scheme of things you know
in reading the book and following the
story you know I'm kind of torn between
two interpretations one is that you know
is this
a case of kind of market failure in the
sense that it went on for so long and it
got you know a lot of money I mean it
hosed you know Rupert Murdoch for over a
hundred million dollars it's catered
around regulations which I can kind of
understand I'm a good libertarian I get
that you know they capture their you
know you work around that is it market
failure in the sense that it took so
long to come out or is a kind of market
success because it did unravel because
of all of the different institutions in
a in a kind of market system what's the
kind of big disposition of this story I
think its market failure in one key way
which is that Walgreens was a key
linchpin here an enabler in the sense
that it helped the Thera notes
commercialize the blood tests and make
him available directly to patients and
Walgreens you would think would have
done its due diligence and would have
vetted the technology and
incomprehensibly did not do so and
because of Walgreens is failure to vet
and to do due diligence she was able to
go live with the technology and then in
late 2013 approached investors and say
look obviously my product is for real
and I've really done what I am saying
I've done because you know we're
offering the service in Walgreens stores
Walgreens wouldn't be letting us do this
if it weren't real and if the tests
weren't accurate and that suckered in
investors like partner fund management
the San Francisco hedge fund they'd put
in almost a hundred million and it
suckered in the other billionaire
investors the likes of Rupert Murdoch
Betsy DeVos and her family which put in
a hundred million dollars
the Coxes which controlled Cox
Enterprises in Atlanta put in a hundred
million dollars the Waltons the heirs of
Sam Walton who founded Walmart they put
in 150 million via to investment
vehicles and they were in large part
sold on the investment but by the notion
that the the product was already
commercialized what is the lesson for
the press do you think as well as
consumers of the press you know whether
or not you're gonna you're in a position
to invest a hundred million dollars in
something you know what what what do
or what do media people and consumers of
media need to take away from this story
it to me it's not just the media and
consumers of the media it's really
American society at large we've come to
deify these these young you know college
dropouts who found these startups in
Silicon Valley and attract a lot of
funding and pretty soon become these
unicorns you know which is the term
that's been coined to to describe
companies private companies that have
reached a valuation of a billion dollars
of more Thera notes by the way achieved
at its peak evaluation of ten billion
dollars and for a couple months there it
was more valuable than uber Airbnb and
Spotify not many people realize that I
think the lesson is that these are in
the end these are just young kids and
you know we we've turned them into these
icons and these heroes and they've
become what you know our children aspire
to be when they come out of college and
graduate school and I think the Thera
knows scandal should make us re-examine
this whole value system final point what
what is Elizabeth Holmes up to and you
play out the final weeks of fairness
right so she's essentially now turning
the lights off
she laid off another 100 employees about
a month and a half ago so the headcount
of the company is down to about 20
employees that same day she sent out an
email to investors explaining that the
cash level the company was going to drop
below three million dollars the summer
at which point the private equity firm
fortress will be able to seize their
knows assets and liquidate it so we're
very likely looking at a liquidation of
fairness as a company by August the
company will have ceased to exist by
then and I hear from my sources that
Elizabeth is telling people even though
she's been charged with fraud by the SEC
and she has settled those charges
without admitting or denying wrongdoing
she's telling people she's going to
start a new company I think the odds of
that happening or are pretty low because
a lot of people forget there's been a
second investigation going on a criminal
one it's been spearheaded by the US
Attorney's Office in San Francisco it's
two and a half years old at this point
it's very advanced and I think criminal
indictments of Elizabeth Holmes at Sonny
ball wanting her ex-boyfriend or a
distinct possibility well we will leave
it there we have been talking with John
Kerry who it's the Wall Street Journal
reporter and the author of bad blood
secrets and lies and a Silicon Valley
startup for reason I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]